everyone loves the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
everyone loves Keanu Reeves how long
before the two shall meet in a chat with
comic-book coms Brandon Davis Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige revealed
that the studio has had Reeves in mind
for a long long time and that they're
just waiting for the right role for the
beloved actor to present itself 5ds
remarks came in response to a line of
questioning which she's got to be used
to by now as Davis wanted to know which
of his favorite actors might be up for
an invitation to the MCU the first name
on his list none other than Keanu Reeves
who at the moment is having something of
a career resurgence yes way with a
chuckle Feige
admitted we talked to him for almost
every film we make we talked to Keanu
Reeves often I don't know when if or
ever he'll join the MCU but we very much
want to figure out the right way to do
it
Feige went on to compare the situation
to Marvel's pursuit of another
high-profile actor who recently joined
the party Jake Gyllenhaal whom he said
the studio had conversations with quote
multiple times before finally casting
him as Quentin Beck aka Mysterio in the
upcoming spider-man far from home this
is mr. bet you could use someone like
you on my world new world
Feige expressed his hope that the same
patient approach would eventually pay
off with Reeves he conspicuously did not
mention the fact that multiple outlets
have reported the star to be in talks
for the Eternals
which is looking to be the first major
release on the cosmic side of Marvel's
face for fyg ease remarks are lent
credence by the fact that way back in
2014
Reeves was rumored to be up for the
title role in Doctor Strange a role
which eventually fell into the very
capable hands of British actor Benedict
Cumberbatch at the time Reeves responded
to the rumors with a mix of excitement
and trepidation while he admitted to
watching and enjoying superhero flicks
claiming that he quote grew up on them
and comics and graphic novels he
admitted to being leery of signing the
kind of multiple picture deal which
Marvel famously requires of its more
high-profile stars
he told Collider from a practical
standpoint the idea of a longtime
contract is sort of a
because you want to make sure the
material is up to a certain level like
the good or a great level I think with
superhero pictures you need the material
you need the director who you think can
deliver a vision you don't want to do it
for doing it you know you want to try
and make sure it's doing something at
this point Reeves doesn't have to do
anything just for the sake of doing it
the star is having the kind of moment
that would make Piers green with envy if
he weren't such a legitimately
breathtaking guy after rocketing to the
a-list thanks to his role as neo in the
matrix series Reeves spent the next
decade or so appearing in decidedly
smaller projects before stumbling upon
his next paradigm-shifting franchise
that would be John wick the insanely
innovative and box-office decimating
shoot-'em-up series which firmly
cemented his status as an action movie
legend Reeves also made a splash this
year in the rapturously received Netflix
rom-com always be my maybe and as duke
kaboom in Toy Story 4 which has blown
critics out of their seats on top of all
this he'll soon be returning to one of
his most fondly remembered roles that of
Ted Theodore Logan the time-traveling
rocker with a heart of gold in next
year's long-awaited threequel
Bill and Ted faced the music oh and he's
set to appear in CD Projekt Reds 20/20
video game cyberpunk 2077 playing wait
for it a dude named Johnny silver hand
wigs a samurai
we have a city to burn
the guy can seemingly do it all so with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe dominating
pop culture like nothing else in recent
memory the time seems oso right for
Feige and company to find that perfect
role that they've long been seeking for
the star check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]